I know most of you know that Donald
Trump lies but here's a hilarious story
Trump often has stories about his black
friend or his veteran friend that type
of thing where he says oh yeah I know my
black friend told me this or my veteran
friend told me that normal people would
see how much Trump lies and immediately
suspect that those stories are also lies
Trump has been selling a telling or
selling it I guess we could say both
ways he's been telling a similar story
about his Jewish friend and every time
the Jewish friend is somebody else this
is just the best Trump told basically
the same story on September 9th December
7th and twice on December 11th at
different events the context is always
that Trump says he did the right thing
by getting out of the Iran deal and he
supports this by saying even my Jewish
friend came to me and said the best
thing wasn't you know moving the embassy
or whatever the best thing was getting
out of that Iran deal the first time he
mentioned that it was people who were
telling him this the second time Trump
told the story verbatim he said it was
big Republican donor Sheldon Adelson who
told him this then the third time he
told the story it was the owner of the
New England Patriots NFL football team
Bob Kraft who told him this and then the
fourth time that he was praised for
getting out of the Iran deal it was the
father of his son-in-law Jared Kushner
Charles Kushner check out this
compilation video with Trump telling the
same story four times each time naming
somebody else
[Music]
I said to Sheldon what do you think was
bigger Israel and the embassy going in
and it became Jerusalem the capital of
Israel or the Golan Heights he said
neither he said the biggest thing you
did for Israel was breaking up and
terminating the horrible one-sided
catastrophic deal that was made by
President Obama I said Bob Kraft which
is bigger which is more important to the
Jewish people that said neither I said
what does that mean he said what you did
by terminating the Iran nuclear deal is
bigger than both I think that's cool and
then I asked Charlie Kushner I said
Charlie let me ask you what's bigger for
the Jewish people giving the embassy to
Jerusalem it becomes the capital of
Israel what's bigger that or the Golan
Heights he said neither I said what does
that mean he said the biggest thing of
all is what you did by ending the Iran
nuclear catastrophe I think that's true
apparently Trump has asked this question
many times and all of his Jewish friends
seemed to be giving him the same answer
right he's having trouble keeping the
lies straight that's what's going on we
recently did a segment about compulsive
lying and here we are with a great
example Trump lies so much it's so
second nature to him to make stuff up
that he can't keep the lies straight or
he has those delusions where he thinks
nobody will notice and he just tells the
story differently each time for kicks
much like many of the compulsive liars
that I've known in my life and of course
if you call them out if you on December
11th after Trump did the first event and
said hey Bob Kraft said this to me and
in the second event it was Charlie
Kushner who said this to him if you said
you know you just told the same story
and named two different people
he would come up with something he would
say well it was actually both of them
who said it to me or he would say well
both basically said the same thing
Orwell Kushner said it before and Kraft
said it more recently and both stories
are true I just told them out of order I
get a lot of emails that say David this
is very clear evidence of dementia and
I've said before Trump may have
cognitive decline but Trump clearly
remembers enough that he could tell this
story one way every time if it was a
real story actual possible cognitive
decline aside we're letting him off the
hook when we say this is merely dementia
this is merely cognitive decline this is
a liar who lies so much that he probably
is not remembering which lies he's told
who he's told them to and this is what
you end up with as a final result even
the American right should be scared to
death that this guy has control over
nuclear weapons he has a huge degree of
control over the financial future of the
United States this is very scary stuff
because he's lying about insignificant
things as we know crowd size hand size I
think you know what I mean these Jewish
friends who tell him the stuff but he's
also lying about really really big
things as well and we've reported on
many of them this is scary stuff this is
the stuff of nightmares and now let's
actually step back a little bit and
quantify the dishonesty and frame it
historically in terms of what we're now
experiencing I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in
one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com /p a que ma n